you're an entrepreneur you just started
a business and you're asking that
question everybody struggles with who do
I hire first as my first employee do I
hire somebody in sales marketing
operations accounting finance product
development legal who do I hire first
right now before I answer that question
for it's a very simple answer but before
I answer a question for you you got to
keep one thing in mind if you're a
start-up and you're an entrepreneur and
you're already funded you have money
that group that gave you the money is
already expecting you to have a team
together because they're not going to
give you the money without you having a
team to show here so I have okay I'm
assuming that I'm talking to the group
that doesn't have money today you're
without money you're trying to stretch
every dollar your were multiple half to
yourself like you're the CEO CFO CEO CMO
you're every single thing in the company
you're doing right now just what happens
your business cards the CEO so who do
you hire first look you got a lot of
departments and a lot of people will
tell you who to hire first for me it's a
very simple thing to be processing and
thinking about so look at it this way
any sports team that already has a
position if a team already has a
quarterback you're going to go get
another quarterback know if a team
already has a very very strong center
you're going to go get another center
know if you're running a business
whatever your strength is the first
person you hire is your opposing
strength
that's your first hire you're posing
strength well Pat what do you mean the
posing strength if you're in sales most
salespeople who are very very good in
sales are not necessarily very good in
operations okay now if you're very good
at operations you're probably not very
good in sales if you're incredible
optronic development most product
development people don't like to be
around a lot of people so you need sales
if you're in sales and you're great
sales person like Ray Kroc but you don't
know what product to develop you need
somebody here if you're someone who's
very good with money and maybe even you
have money but you don't have an idea
maybe you meet up there but the point
I'm making two years whatever your
opposing strength is that's what you
need to start off with now let's say
this other
for you to be thinking about I'll go dig
it dig a little bit deeper in the game
of sports everybody that builds a team
they generally build it around their
philosophy of what's the most important
thing to invest their money into let me
explain what I mean by this some teams
build around one player okay so for
instance Chicago Bulls Michael Jordan
they built around one player Michael
Jordan was the main player then they
brought supporting cast to be around him
right a you know San Antonio Spurs built
around a system they're not building
around one personality one player that's
why they've been playing for 20 years
and they're winning 20 years whether
they go from David Robinson to Duncan to
LaMarcus Aldridge and Kawhi Leonard it's
a it's a system they're building it on
right I don't know what you're going to
be building your business and your
philosophy in your system on but what I
could tell you is whoever you choose as
your first next determines what you
value the most sometimes sometimes
generally the most logical people the
the people that are most esses and
everything to them is very logical and
very organized like the administrator
folks sometimes they think is a need is
sometimes they think they need product
development only logical sometimes they
just go those everything is just way too
illogical and they forget that you need
sales if you don't have somebody selling
you you don't have volume revenues
coming if there's no sales going on done
it's just it's purely a done deal right
so back in the days when a lot of
companies would do very very well and
they would develop these guys that will
become the fields of the company
everybody who got started with the
company back in 260 70s you read about
they all have to do sales at one point
of their career why because that's what
touch the customer to know what the
customers like that is my focus I like
to hire this first so if you're not
sales I like to hire this first when I
got started I'll say for myself I was
this first and I'm marketing this is me
so guess what I need it I need it here I
partnered up with here somebody that
designed the products that I needed so
without this I don't have a product to
sell so I got product to sell and I'm
admin then I got this I already have
somebody that was helping me out with
this but then I got this then I upgraded
just a whole different level so as
you're thinking about this with your
business whatever business you're
running take the sheet of paper or take
the sheet of paper out and ask yourself
what is my strengths and what are the
opposing strengths that I need go
recruit that person go hire that person
stop hiring people that are just like
yourself it's cool to be around people
that are just like yourself it's fun
when you're around people like yourself
that's good maybe when you have a
friendship but not when you're running a
business you're trying to win a create a
business and a business if you run out
of this you shut down the business
you're going back to having a job so you
got to make sure you make the decision
of who you hire first in a very very
proper way or else you won't be in
business for too long hey thanks for
watching this video let me make a case
to you I believe you need to subscribe
to value team and also join a
notification squad look there's two ways
you can learn about business one of the
ways to go to college
learn a bunch of theories by professors
who I probably never run a business
before or you can watch value tainment
ran by entrepreneurs who have built and
sold businesses and you can learn from
our mistakes and what we did right and
by the way I'm willing to bet anybody
who goes and takes this boring route
verses watches I attainment I'm putting
my money this person who watches value
10 is going to beat the person who goes
to college you don't believe me test me
on this this is why I'm so certain you
need to subscribe to value tainment and
learn the content so you can also be
successful
[Music]